the one it's interesting that in a way
that judges quite decisively and
carefully cutting away all the
unnecessary evidence all that she deems
to be unsubstantiated unreliable or not
central to the case what is interesting
thus far is that she used a lot of the
word gut unreliable it pops up every now
and then and thus far obviously that is
in favor of the defense case but this
morning in the span of two hours she
basically fire lives and summarized the
the state's case and two large extend
the sparks you rejected it she's already
at the stage where she now must make a
credibility finding on the evidence and
defense would defenses of Oscar
Pistorius himself now depending on what
way this is turns out this should give
him a real indication where we going by
thus far I am personally of the view
that it seems to me that premeditated
murder is out of the door thus for
murder not necessarily yet remember
during the course of any judgment
sometimes the judgments ways one way or
another as things go along and only
ultimately you'll find out what the end
result is I